WandaVision proves that you don't always necessarily
need to jump into the meat of a story.
You can take your time, forcing the audience
to question your motives and speculate as
to where, precisely, you're heading.
That was the case with Episode 1 of the hit
Disney+ original, as the series followed a
pretty straightforward sitcom plot.
With each passing episode, the audience receives
more information until the explosive final
scene in Episode 5 when Wanda and Vision hear
a knock at the door and discover it's Wanda's
brother, Pietro.
Only it's not the MCU Quicksilver played by
Aaron Taylor-Johnson who bit the dust in Age
of Ultron; it's Evan Peters, who played the
superhero in the 20th Century Studios X-Men
movies.
We've known for a while that Peters would
make an appearance on WandaVision, resulting
in rampant fan theories that his presence
would open up the gates between the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and the larger Marvel multiverse,
which includes the X-Men.
However, given his brief introduction, there's
still a lot we don't know.
Is this actually the Quicksilver we last saw
in X-Men: Dark Phoenix?
Is this a different guy who happens to look
like Evan Peters?
And what did Darcy mean with this line?
"She recast Pietro?"
Things are only going to get crazier from
here as we get into the final four episodes.
Fortunately, show creator Jac Schaeffer sat
down with Marvel.com to discuss the phenomenal
casting coup and how exactly it came to be.
By the sound of it, Schaeffer knew early on
she wanted to try to bring Peters' Quicksilver
back, but naturally, that led to a fair share
of challenges.
As she explains,
"That's the thing, you can hatch a million
great ideas, but to make them land, to make
them be grounded, to make them feel organic
to the larger story ..."
This sentiment and the idea that his role
had to make sense in the overall structure
of the series was echoed by Marvel Studios
president Kevin Feige.
Schaeffer continued,
"Kevin wanted to make sure that there was
a reason for it, that it made sense.
And I hope that's what we did."
It's safe to say the mission was accomplished,
and given the fact that Vision actor Paul
Bettany has said that a massive cameo would
be coming down the line, Quicksilver's entrance
won't be the only thing that blows our mind
with this show.
It's such a trippy series that it would be
easy to go overboard with craziness, but grounding
things in some definition of reality helps
keep the show honest.
Schaeffer further expounds upon this, saying,
"This show is such a mind scramble, and because
it's working on so many levels, and there's
so many notions of what's real and what's
not, and performance, and casting, and audience,
and fandom, and all of that, we just thought
it would be the biggest thrill to bring Evan
over to the Marvel Cinematic Universe."
All questions regarding where, exactly, this
new Quicksilver came from and what his role
will be going forward will receive answers
eventually, and for the time being, we already
have a good idea of what his role in the sitcom
world will be.
Darcy saying that Wanda "recast" her deceased
brother wasn't just a throwaway line.
Recasting characters, even prominent ones,
in sitcoms is a common trope that can be seen
time and time again.
Just take Bewitched, which replaced Dick York
with Dick Sargent as co-lead halfway through
the series.
Of course, modern audiences may be more familiar
with Janet Hubert-Whitten departing the role
of Aunt Viv on The Fresh Prince of Bel-Air
after feuding with star Will Smith and getting
replaced with Daphne Maxwell Reid.
Replacing Taylor-Johnson's Quicksilver with
Evans' version just makes sense.
WandaVision had to recast Pietro to further
solidify its sitcom influences, and it undoubtedly
sets up some bigger surprises in the weeks
to come.
To see how all this plays out, keep checking
in with WandaVision every Friday on Disney+.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
comic characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.